إنها الساعة السابعة صباحًا في شرق ليبيا حيث
تطالب السلطات بإجراء
تحقيق في
الفيضانات الكارثية التي وقعت هذا الأسبوع والتي أودت بحياة أكثر
من 5000 شخص، وتقول الأمم المتحدة إنه كان من
الممكن تجنب معظم الوفيات من خلال
التحذيرات المناسبة وعمليات الإجلاء.
يمكن أن يصل ديتول في النهاية إلى
20000. تقول المجموعة إن موجة سبعة أمتار
اجتاحت المدينة عندما
انهار سدان وجرفت كل شيء في
طريقها
[موسيقى]
ثم أصبح المطر أكثر هدوءًا في الساعة
2:45 صباحًا، ماذا يمكنني أن أخبرك بالضبط عن
الفيضان الكبير  جاء كان مثل
مشهد خيالي كان مثل الكابوس
لا أعرف كيف أصفه
الماء صعد إلى الطابق الثاني ثم
إلى الطابق الثالث صعدت إلى السطح
جيراني يصرخون ويطلبون
المساعدة نزلت  لمساعدتهم ورأيت
أحد جيراني ميتًا ويأخذه
الفيضان أخذت الأطفال
وصعدت مرة أخرى وقد
تهدم المبنى وسور المبنى إنا لله
وإنا إليه راجعون
إنه يتدفق على المدينة ولكن
تقول السلطات إنها بحاجة إلى متطوعين
لجمع الموتى ودفنهم جيدًا. تفيد
تقارير اليونيسف أن ما يصل إلى 300 ألف طفل معرضون
لخطر المرض والنزوح.
وتطلب الأمم المتحدة أكثر من 71 مليون
دولار من عمال الإغاثة العاجلة في درنة الذين
قضوا جزءًا من يومهم في الفرز.
الملابس وغيرها من العناصر للأشخاص
المحتاجين، والميناء البحري في درنة
مفتوح الآن أمام السفن التي تقوم بتوصيل الموردين بشكل جيد.
وصلت جامايكا من CNN إلى درنة ليبيا منذ
وقت قصير وقدمت هذا التقرير،
وقد استغرقنا أكثر من سبع ساعات للوصول
من بنغازي إلى المدينة  من الظهرنة
وهي رحلة تستغرق عادة
حوالي ثلاث ساعات وذلك لأن
العديد من الطرق والعديد من الجسور حول ميتنا
قد دمرت ويمكنك أن تتخيل
ما يعنيه ذلك بالنسبة لمساعدات
الإغاثة والدعم الذي سيأتي
إلى  المدينة ومدى صعوبة
الأمر في هذا الوقت والقيادة
ليلاً، شعرت وكأنها مدينة أشباح، إنها
هادئة بشكل مخيف وفي كل مكان تنظر إليه
ترى الضرر والدمار، الجو مظلم،
إنه وقت الليل ولكن لا يزال بإمكاننا رؤية
الكثير من الدمار هنا.
فقط يبدو الأمر وكأنه منطقة حرب، يبدو الأمر
كما لو أن قنبلة قد انفجرت هنا، لقد انفجرت قنبلة كبيرة
هنا ومن الصعب جدًا أن
نقف هنا ولا
نتخيل ما مر به الناس في هذه المدينة حيث
فقد الآلاف من الأشخاص حياتهم
أكثر من عشرة آلاف  الآن
مجهول المصير وكل من تتحدث إليه
يسمع مخاوف من أن حفرة الغبار
سترتفع في الأيام القادمة وكل
هذا الدمار والخسائر في الأرواح التي
يخبرنا بها المسؤولون أن كل هذا
حدث في أقل من ساعتين وربما
ساعة ونصف  يعتقدون أنه بعد
انفجار تلك السدود
واجتياح المياه للمدينة مما أدى إلى تدمير
أحياء بأكملها، كما يقولون،
جرفت المباني والبنية التحتية والمدن
ومنازل العائلات في البحر، إنه أمر
لا يمكن تصوره ما حدث في
المدينة وقد ترك الكثير من الناس هنا
في حالة صدمة  يخبرنا الليبيون أنهم معتادون على
الحرب، إنهم معتادون على الموت، إنهم معتادون
على الخسارة ولكن لا شيء كان يمكن أن
يعدهم لذلك أثناء رحلتنا إلى الضنة،
رأينا الكثير من السيارات القادمة من
أجزاء مختلفة من البلاد من
بعيد  الليبيون الغربيون من الجنوب
يجتمعون هنا لتقديم المساعدات
للمتطوعين لدعم الناس في هذا
الجزء من البلاد وشعب
الضنة ويبدو أن هذا
البلد المنقسم قد اجتمع معًا وأن هذه
المأساة وهذه الخسارة جمعتهم معًا
على الأقل  في الوقت الحالي،
تروي سي إن إن أوليفيا
في ليبيا قصصًا مروعة عن الجثث التي
تتراكم وتملأ الشوارع بعد
الفيضانات العارمة عندما
هطلت أمطار غزيرة على سدين
وجرفت المنازل وكل شيء في
طريق المياه حيث بدأت تلك الدولة في
حساب التكلفة التي تزيد عن ستة آلاف على
افتراض  قتلى وأخيرًا، تم تهجير حوالي عشرة
آلاف مفقود وثلاثين ألفًا آخرين،
هذه
أعداد هائلة في دولة فاشلة
تحتاج إلى المساعدة بشكل عاجل كما أفاد المراسل بن
ويدمان الآن وتحذير
بالطبع بعض المشاهد يصعب
رؤية
الجثث في كل مكان  العشرات
من القتلى مغطى بالبطانيات في انتظار
تحديد هويتهم ودفنهم.
عدد القتلى بالآلاف ولكن حتى
الآن لا أحد يعرف حقًا عدد الذين
نقلتهم العاصفة دانيال.
الناجون يعثرون على المزيد والمزيد من
الجثث
وقد انتشل عمال الإنقاذ والمتطوعين
جثة صبي  ملفوفًا
ببطانية ومستعدًا لوضعه في
كيس الجثث عندما يصل والده
متأثرًا بالعاطفة،
يخشى الأطباء أن يؤدي ترك الكثير من الموتى في
العراء إلى تفشي
المرض،
ويقول إننا غير قادرين على التعرف على جميع الجثث ودفنها  هذه المرأة
التي تم تحديدها على أنها الدكتورة عائشة نريد
توفير مكان إنساني للتجميد حيث
يمكن لأحبائهم التعرف عليهم بعد ذلك،
ولا يزال الوصول إلى درنة صعبًا، فقد
دمر الفيضان العديد من الطرق
والجسور المؤدية إلى المدينة،
وقد تحول هذا الميناء الواقع في شرق ليبيا
إلى أرض قاحلة  من الركام الطيني والخراب،
والمياه الهائجة التي مزقت
المدينة لم تدخر أحدًا ولا شيئًا